I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Oh, you're coming in spooky because it is spooked today on Office Ladies. Season 8 Episode 5 written by Carrie Kemper and directed by Randall Einhorn.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，并且是挚友。现在我们正为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身历其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。大家好！哦，你出场时阴森森的，因为今天《办公室》播客要闹鬼啦。第八季第五集，由凯莉·肯珀编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。
Are you ready for a summary? I can't wait. Here it is. Aaron falls short of everyone's expectations when she is put in charge of this year's Halloween party decorations. Her fellow employees step in to salvage the day, but she still fears Andy is gonna fire her. Dwight meets his match when Robert California brings his son to the office, and Jim Heckles Pam for believing in ghosts. Jim, Jim, I have issue with you. We'll get to it. Well, we got mail. Oh, I bet. Fastback number one. This is a Halloween episode.
准备好听剧情总结了吗？我已经迫不及待了。内容是这样的。艾琳被指派负责今年万圣节派对的装饰，却未能达到大家的期望。她的同事们纷纷出手救场，但她依然担心安迪会解雇她。罗伯特·卡利福尼亚把儿子带到办公室，让德怀特棋逢对手；吉姆则因为吉姆相信鬼神而对她百般调侃。吉姆，吉姆，我对你有意见。我们待会儿会说到。好吧，我们收到邮件了。哦，我敢打赌。快讯一。这是一个万圣节主题的集。
This is only the third Halloween episode where it was Halloween all day. Oh, yeah, our first one was in season two Halloween. And then we had season seven just last year costume contest. And we have had like cold opens or nods to Halloween, but we got to wear our costumes all week for this episode. I was not happy about it. I had that pregur belly unit hard thing. Okay, imagine this guys. You step into a unit hard. I know we've talked about this so much, but it's got like a pillow in it. You strap that thing on you, it goes over your bra and you're underwear. Then you put on knitted tights, knitted tights that go over all of that, then you put on this long kind of, I don't know, knitted long top, then you put a furry skirt with a wire tail over all of
这仅仅是第三个全天都在过万圣节的万圣节剧集。哦，对，我们的第一个万圣节是在第二季。然后我们有第七季，就在去年的服装大赛。虽然我们有过几次冷开场或向万圣节致敬的桥段，但在这集里，我们一整周都穿着万圣节服装。对此我可不太高兴。我当时挺着那个假孕肚，感觉很吃力。好吧，大家想象一下。你穿上一套假孕肚。我知道我们已经讨论过很多次了，但它里面好像有个枕头。你把它绑在身上，它会从你的胸罩和内衣外面罩过去。然后你要穿上针织紧身裤，把所有这些都包住的针织紧身裤，接着你还要穿上一件长款的，我不知道，针织长衫，然后再穿上一条带毛绒裙边和铁丝尾巴的裙子，把所有这些都
that. I've never been more comfortable than I was in my kangaroo out. You know what, you know what, lady? I loved it. Your kangaroo outfit was my penguin. Yes. Well, listen, Angela, since we're talking about costumes, we got a fan question from Emily B and Boone North Carolina who said, can we get a costume breakdown
我穿着袋鼠服的时候从来没有这么舒服过。你知道吗，你知道吗，女士？我很喜欢。你的袋鼠装就像我的企鹅装一样。没错。好吧，听着，安吉拉，既然我们在讨论服装，我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州布恩的艾米莉·B的一个粉丝提问，她说，我们能看看
for everyone in this episode? Come on, North Carolina. You know I got your back. I am ready, Emily, with my costume breakdown. Here we go. Angela is her OG cat costume. Pam, as you heard as a kangaroo, I want you to know, in the shooting draft, it said, Pam is dressed as a kangaroo with a stuffed animal peeking out of the pouch. And there was. You carried that around all week. Phyllis was a burlust dancer, Stanley, a chef. Aaron is windy from the Wendy's fast food chain. Andy is a construction worker. Darryl, Kevin and Jim were NBA basketball players from the Miami Heat at the time. LeBron James, Duane Wade and Chris Bosch.
这集中每个人的服装解析吗？太棒了，北卡罗来纳州。你知道我挺你。艾米莉，我已经准备好我的服装解析了。我们开始吧。安吉拉是她标志性的猫咪装。正如你所听到的，帕姆是一只袋鼠，我想让你们知道，在拍摄剧本里写着：帕姆打扮成一只袋鼠，育儿袋里还探出一个毛绒动物。确实如此。你一整周都带着它。菲莉丝是滑稽舞女郎，斯坦利是大厨。艾琳是温蒂汉堡快餐连锁店的温蒂。安迪是建筑工人。达里尔、凯文和吉姆当时是迈阿密热火队的NBA篮球运动员。勒布朗·詹姆斯、德怀恩·韦德和克里斯·波什。
Creed was Osama bin Laden. Dwight is Carrigan from Starcraft. And I'm sorry folks, I had to Google Starcraft. I wasn't sure what it is. It's like a real-time strategy game, Jenna. Can you play it? No. Okay, me either.
克里德是奥萨马·本·拉登。德怀特是《星际争霸》里的凯瑞甘。很抱歉各位，我不得不谷歌了一下《星际争霸》。我不太确定那是什么。它就像一款即时战略游戏，詹娜。你会玩吗？不会。好吧，我也不会。
Ryan is Jesse Pinkman from Breaking Bad. Gabe Toby and Kelly are all skeletons. Oscar is a liar Anthony Weiner, based on a New York City politician who was involved in a sexting scandal back then. Meredith got to be Kate Middleton. She elbowed Kelly out for that one. Her costume might be my favorite.
瑞安是《绝命毒师》里的杰西·平克曼。盖比、托比和凯莉都是骷髅。奥斯卡是那个满口谎言的安东尼·韦纳，原型是一位卷入色情短信丑闻的纽约市政治家。梅雷迪思扮演的是凯特·米德尔顿。她为此把凯利挤走了。她的服装可能是我最喜欢的。
It's a white t-shirt with some duct tape. It's like amazing and a crown. Robert California is Jack Nicholson. Yep, the scene was extended in the shooting draft where he actually says that he's Jack Nicholson. And his son, Bert, is zombie from the walking dead. I Think that's everybody. Oh, oh, oh Emily in North Carolina. I have more for you I'm not done because I also did the costumes in the Toby and Dwight flashback sequence
那是一件印有几条电工胶带的白T恤。真是绝了，还有一个王冠。罗伯特·卡利福尼亚是杰克·尼科尔森。没错，拍摄剧本里还有一段加长的场景，他甚至在里面说自己就是杰克·尼科尔森。他的儿子伯特是《行尸走肉》里的僵尸。我想这就是所有人了吧。哦，哦，哦，北卡罗来纳州的艾米莉。我还有更多内容要告诉你，还没完呢，因为我还整理了托比和德怀特闪回镜头里的服装。
I got so excited. I forgot I did that Dwight was Billy the saw puppet Freddie Krueger and hell razor Oh, and then also he had the big wings, you know, full of blades for Carrigan. And then Toby was a hippie and a pirate and maybe, maybe it looks like from the back a priest. Well, Angela, I thought that was an excellent costume breakdown. I think Emily is going to be very happy with that. Should we move on to fast-fac- number two?
我太兴奋了。我都忘了我做了这个。德怀特扮演了竖锯木偶比利、弗莱迪·克鲁格和猛鬼追魂。哦，还有，他为了扮演凯瑞甘还戴着装满刀刃的大翅膀。然后托比扮演了一个嬉皮士和一个海盗，而且可能，从背面看起来像是一个神父。好吧，安吉拉，我觉得这是一个非常棒的服装解析。我想艾米莉一定会非常满意。我们要进入快讯二吗？
Yes. Fast-fac- number two is a fan question from Angie D in Mexico. I love Robert California son. Oh, lots of O's. Lots of O's and ball caps. He is such a talented actor. What can you tell us about him? Well, Angie, we agree with you.
好。快讯二是来自墨西哥的安吉·D的一个粉丝提问。我太喜欢罗伯特·卡利福尼亚的儿子了。哦，好多惊叹号。好多感叹号和棒球帽。他是个极具天赋的演员。关于他，你们能告诉我们什么吗？好吧，安吉，我们同感。
We thought he was incredible. His character is Bert and he was played by David Mizzouz. Incredible. I mean, the presence, the talent that this kid had. Just the confidence. Like, he went toe-to-toe with Reign. Who could be, you know, a little scary. Yeah.
我们觉得他棒极了。他的角色叫伯特，由大卫·马祖尔饰演。太棒了。我是说，这个孩子身上的气场和天赋。简直充满了自信。就像，他能和雷恩针锋相对。雷恩有时候，你知道，可能会有点吓人。是的。
Yeah. He was amazing. Now, you might recognize him because he played Bruce Wayne on the television show Gotham. Oh my God. Yes. Oh my God. Yeah.
是的。他太惊艳了。现在，你可能会认出他，因为他在电视剧《哥谭》里饰演过布鲁斯·韦恩。噢天哪。没错。噢天哪。是的。
No way. I'm just putting it together. Yeah. He started working in commercials when he was eight and then he starred on Gotham from the age of 13 to 18. He now attends Stanford University. He's pursuing a degree in economics and psychology. I think he graduates this year, but get this.
不会吧。我刚把他们联系起来。是的。他从八岁开始拍广告，然后从13岁到18岁主演了《哥谭》。他现在就读于斯坦福大学。他在攻读经济学和心理学学位。我想他今年就要毕业了，但你听这个。
Here's a little bit of trivia about him. His birthday is February 19th, which is the same as Batman, who David played on Gotham. Same birthday as Batman. It's just crazy. It was meant to be. And now, fast back number three, this episode was Kareza from a production standpoint for several reasons.
这里有一点关于他的冷知识。他的生日是2月19日，这和蝙蝠侠的生日是同一天，而大卫在《哥谭》里演的就是蝙蝠侠。和蝙蝠侠同一天生日。这简直太疯狂了。这就是命中注定。现在，快讯三，从制作的角度来看，这一集简直是一场灾难，原因有几个。
First of all, we were starting to cross-board. That is when you shoot two episodes at once. And I am very sorry, but I was the reason for the cross-boarding. I was getting really close to my due date. We were shooting both this episode and parts of Pam's replacement, all in this same week. They were doing that so that they would shoot me on Mondays and Tuesdays, and then they would shoot everybody else the rest of the week.
首先，我们开始交叉拍摄了。也就是同时拍摄两集。非常抱歉，我就是导致交叉拍摄的原因。我离预产期越来越近了。我们在这同一周里，既在拍这一集，又在拍帕姆的替代者的戏份。他们这么做是为了让我周一和周二拍摄，然后在剩余的一周里拍摄其他所有人。
They were always trying to get my work done in the first two days of the week in case I went into labor. We didn't know if we were going or coming. Whenever we did this cross-board stuff and we had done it before. You know? Oh, yeah, but I was like, wait, wait, what am I putting on? Where am I? What's the scene?
他们总是尽量把我的工作安排在一周的前两天完成，以防我突然临盆。我们完全不知道拍摄进度是怎样的。每当我们进行这种交叉拍摄的时候——我们以前也做过。你知道吗？哦，对，但我当时的状态是，等等，等等，我穿的是什么？我在哪？这场戏是怎样的？
We also reserved one entire day to shoot the opening skit for the Emmys, the 2011 Emmys. I found it on YouTube. It's really fun. This is the one where all these different actors from different TV shows came on to the set of the office as their characters. Yeah. Yeah. And they were all just like talking about their workplaces as if they were doing a talking head on the office. But there were also little scenes. So like, for example, at one point, Aaron Paul comes in. He's being Jesse Pinkman, which it's ironic that
我们还腾出一整天的时间来拍摄2011年艾美奖的开场短片。我在YouTube上找到了。真的非常有趣。就是这个短片，来自不同电视剧的各种演员以他们角色的身份来到了《办公室》的片场。对。对。他们都在谈论自己的工作场所，就好像他们在《办公室》里做单人访谈一样。但里面也有一些小场景。所以，比如说，有一幕，亚伦·保尔进来了。他扮演的是杰西·平克曼，这就很讽刺了，
later Ryan is Jesse Pinkman for Halloween, that this was all happening at the same week. But Aaron Paul comes on and he's looking for Creed. and he's weirded out that there's all these cameras and Creed's like, don't worry about it. It's not a big deal. And then he hands Creed like a little paper bag and then Creed yells, I got my crystal mess. And then as Jesse Pinkman, he's all weirded out and he like runs away. Aaron Paul is so nice. So nice. So nice. Just a really great guy. Yeah. And then there were all kinds of stars, like from 30 Rock and Parks and Recreation and Mad Men, Law and Order SVU, even Kim Kardashian.
后来瑞安在万圣节也扮演了杰西·平克曼，而这一切竟然都发生在同一周。但亚伦·保尔出场了，他在找克里德。而且他对这里有这么多摄像机感到很怪异，克里德就说，别担心。这没什么大不了的。然后他递给克里德一个小纸袋，接着克里德大喊，我拿到我的冰毒啦。然后作为杰西·平克曼，他觉得超级诡异，然后就跑开了。亚伦·保尔人太好了。太好了。太好了。真的是个极好的家伙。是的。然后还有各种各样的明星，比如来自《我为喜剧狂》、《公园与游憩》、《广告狂人》、《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》的演员，甚至还有金·卡戴珊。
I was talking with Steve Burgess about this and he said that he produced this whole thing and that most of the actors really did come in and sit in our conference room to do these talking heads and you can see Leslie David Baker sitting in the background of all of these talking heads. Leslie David Baker, talk about someone who showed up every day and was just such a trooper because those talking heads sometimes took a really long time. I know. He was there. He was. There was also a talking head that we did with Silo Green, who happened to be a judge on the voice that season. And we brought in one of those giant chairs.
我跟史蒂夫·伯吉斯聊过这事，他说整个这部分都是他制作的，而且大多数演员确实都来到了我们的会议室里坐着做这些单人访谈，你甚至能在所有这些单人访谈的背景里看到莱斯利·大卫·贝克坐在那儿。莱斯利·大卫·贝克，说起那种每天都按时出现并且极其配合的人，因为那些单人访谈有时真的要拍很长时间。我懂。他在那儿。他确实在。还有一个单人访谈是我们和希洛·格林一起做的，他恰好是那一季《美国好声音》的导师。我们搬了一把那种巨大的椅子进来。
So he's sitting in one of those giant chairs. Instead of our regular chair, Steve Burgess said in order to get the chair into the conference room, we had to take down the entire wall of the conference room, move the chair in and then rebuild it. Isn't that insane? That's crazy. And then I guess there were a few people who were based in New York, like Tracy Morgan and Mariska Hargote and Kim Kardashian. And in that instance, there was a crew in New York who shot them on a green screen and then we sort of like inserted our background. And then I guess Matt Sone also took a camera around. He went to the Mad Men set and same thing.
所以他就坐在其中一把巨型椅子上。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，为了把这把椅子弄进会议室，我们不得不把会议室整面墙都拆了，把椅子搬进去，然后再重新建好。是不是疯狂至极？太疯狂了。然后我想还有一些演员常住纽约，比如特雷西·摩根、玛莉丝卡·哈吉塔和金·卡戴珊。那种情况下，纽约有个摄制组用绿幕拍了他们，然后我们再把背景给合成进去。接着我想马特·索恩也带着摄像机四处走动。他去了《广告狂人》的片场，也是一样的情况。
He like set up a green screen because that was the only way to grab, you know, those other talking heads. But yeah, this was a big deal. It took 12 hours. A whole day it was our Wednesday. So we cross-borted on Monday Tuesday. And then we did this crazy MEX Traveganza on Wednesday, and then Thursday Friday was like more of spooked.
他架设了一个绿幕，因为那是获取那些其他单人访谈的唯一方法。不过说真的，这可是一件大事。花了12个小时。整整一天，那是我们的周三。所以我们周一周二进行了交叉拍摄。然后我们在周三拍了这个疯狂的艾美奖大杂烩，接着周四和周五基本上就是继续拍《闹鬼》。
It was bonkers. I was curious to see what was happening during the week that we filmed this. I always go and check my email, my digital clutter, just to see. And I actually found this in my digital clutter. Ken Jong emailed me like at 9.52 PM, the day before and said, Hey, Angela, are you going to be on set tomorrow? I'm going to shoot something on your set for the Emmys, and I miss you.
简直乱套了。我很想知道我们拍摄这一周都在发生什么。我总是去查我的邮件、我数码垃圾箱里的东西，只是想看看。我居然在我的数码垃圾箱里找到了这个。金·郑在前一天晚上9点52分给我发了封邮件，上面写着，嘿，安吉拉，你明天会在片场吗？我要为艾美奖在你们片场拍点东西，我想你了。
I hope all's well. Will I see you? Exo, Exo, Ken. Wow. Because we have been friends a long time. We did a movie together years ago called Furry Vengeance, where we played the bad guys. And I wrote back and I said, Ken, I'm so sorry, I'm not in today.
希望一切都好。我会见到你吗？亲亲抱抱，金。哇。因为我们认识很久了。我们多年前一起拍过一部叫《毛茸茸的复仇》的电影，我们在里面演坏人。我回信说，金，太抱歉了，我今天不在。
I'm bummed that I will miss you, have fun. Ah, so it was my day off and I did not come in. Well, Angela, you and I are not in the MEXTRAVAGANCE of thing. I think we had the day off. Yeah, I don't know why I'm not in it. I don't know why you're not in it. Phyllis is also not in it and Kate is not in it.
没能见到你我好失望，祝你玩得开心。啊，所以那天正好是我的休息日，我没去片场。好吧，安吉拉，你和我都没有参与那个艾美奖大杂烩。我想我们那天正好休息。对，我不知道为什么我没演。我也不知道你为什么没演。菲莉丝也没演，凯特也没演。
But, and Ken Jong did not make it in either. So I don't know what he filmed, but I guess he got edited out. Exactly. Well, that's all I got for FastFacts. Should we take a break and then come back and see Andy is reviewing everyone's costumes before they can wear them. Very controlled.
但是，金·郑也没能参演。所以我不知道他到底拍了什么，但我想他大概是被剪掉了。没错。好吧，关于快讯我就知道这么多了。我们要不要休息一下，然后回来看看安吉尔是如何在大家穿上服装之前进行审查的？管控得真严。
Yeah, he's got rules. Yeah. Yeah. We're in Andy's office, and he is stating that he has three rules for the Halloween costumes. Don't be offensive. Don't be cliche. And don't take the first two rules too seriously. Yeah, he's pre-screening costumes this year
对，他有一套规矩。对。我们在安吉的办公室里，他正在声明他为万圣节服装定下了三条规矩。别太具冒犯性。别太流于俗套。别把前两条规矩看得太严肃。对，他今年在对服装进行预先筛选。
He's pretty much saying no to most of the costumes or he's unimpressed. He says yes to Angela's costume I think he scared a firstill He says no to Kevin's girl a costume and he says that Kelly and Meredith cannot both be Kate Middleton Well, he also says no to Philis' sexy bunny costume. Oh, yes. How could I forget that? I had to see what was written in the script about these dueling Kate Middleton costumes because they were so amazing. And here is what it says. Kelly holds a nice white wedding dress in front of her. Meredith has an oversized white t-shirt with a sheet duct taped to the bottom. Yeah.
他基本上对大部分服装都说不，或者说他根本印象深刻。他同意了安吉拉的服装，我想他把菲莉丝吓够呛。他对凯文的变装说不，他说凯莉和梅雷迪思不能同时扮成凯特·米德尔顿。哦，对了，他对菲莉丝的性感兔女郎服装也说了不。哦，对啊！我怎么能把这茬给忘了呢。我得去看看剧本里是怎么写这两个撞衫的凯特·米德尔顿的，因为她们的造型实在太绝了。剧本上是这么写的。凯莉手里拿着一件漂亮的白色婚纱。梅雷迪思穿着一件超大的白T恤，裙摆上贴着一张胶带。对。
Mm-hmm. Yeah, it's brilliant. But this is when we learned that Meredith is a huge fan of the royal family, and she used her sister's funeral as an excuse to go to the wedding. Meredith flew to London, and you know she wasn't invited in the chapel, so that means she's standing out, what? In the the street watching it on a jumbo tron? What? Yeah. What this was one of the biggest jumps for Mary's character for me. I was like, are you serious? I kind of loved it. Andy's gonna arrive to work now as a construction worker and he and Aaron have such an awkward exchange.
嗯哼。没错，这太机智了。但也就是在这时，我们得知梅雷迪思其实是王室的超级粉丝，她把她姐姐的葬礼当成去参加婚礼的借口。梅雷迪思飞去了伦敦，你知道她根本没被邀请进教堂，所以这意味着她只能站在哪？站在街上通过一个巨大屏幕观看？什么？对。这对我来说是梅雷迪思这个角色最大的一次人设跳跃之一。我当时想，你是认真的吗？我其实还挺喜欢的。安吉拉现在以建筑工人的身份去上班，他和艾琳之间的互动简直尴尬极了。
It made me so sad and uncomfortable. And I'm like, what the heck, what happened to them? She's also covering his door with cobwebs. So many cobwebs that you can't enter the office. I hate those stupid cobwebs things. I hate them. I hate our kids love them. They want to put them in the hedge, you know,
这让我感到既难过又别扭。我心里想，搞什么鬼，他们之间到底怎么了？她还在他的门上挂满了蜘蛛网。蜘蛛网多得你都进不去办公室了。我讨厌那些愚蠢的蜘蛛网道具。我太讨厌了。我恨它们，但我们家的小孩却超爱。他们每年都想把它们挂在树篱上，
in the front of the house every year. They loved to put them in the hedge, but guess who's taking them out of the hedge? And this year it rained. And it rained. We had them in our hedge as well. Yeah, it was a tough removal this year. Dwight is going to enter and he's very annoyed that no one knows who he is. Well, you know, I guess Carrigan is the queen of blades, you guys, but he has no blades. Yeah, he blames Toby. And this is when we see the flashback, right? Yeah.
房子正面的树篱上。他们特别喜欢挂在树篱上，但你猜是谁负责把它们从树篱里清理出来的？今年还下雨了。而且下雨了。我们家树篱上也挂了。对啊，今年清理起来可真费劲。德怀特走进来，大家居然都认不出他是谁，这让他非常恼火。好吧，你知道的，凯瑞甘可是刀锋女王，各位，但他身上一把刀刃都没有。对，他把这怪到托比头上。也就是这个时候我们看到了闪回镜头，对吧？对。
Toby has said, Dwight, you cannot bring any weapons into the office. And each year for his Halloween costume, he has to remove something, right? Yep. Well, I found in the shooting draft a candy bag alt must shoot that I think would lie to fire under the theory that Toby is the Scranton Strangler. What? Yeah. This was an alt that they didn't use.
托比当时说，德怀特，你不能把任何武器带进办公室。每年他的万圣节服装都得拿掉点东西，对吧？没错。我在拍摄剧本里发现了一个关于糖果袋的备选拍摄方案，我觉得这个方案能为“托比就是斯克兰顿绞杀魔”这个理论火上浇油。什么？对。这是一个他们没采用的备选方案。
Here it is. Toby would have said, every Halloween I tell him the same thing. You can't have weapons. And every year he says, as soon as I get my weapons back, I will kill you. It's our yearly dance. What he doesn't know is, one day I'm going to kill you. It's our yearly dance. What he doesn't know is one day I'm going to kill him.
内容是这样的。托比当时会说，每个万圣节我都跟他说一样的话。你不能带武器。而他每年都会说，等我拿回武器，我就杀了你。这是我们一年一度的舞蹈。他不知道的是，有一天我要杀了他。这是我们一年一度的舞蹈。他不知道的是有一天我要杀了他。
Not really. I mean, yeah, that sounds serial killer. It sounds grand strangler early. It sure does. Can't say it. And then he goes not really. And he has a little laugh. Just saying found it in the candy bag. Well, you had a great candy bag, all I had a sighting of candy at two minutes and 39 seconds, a giant tub of candy corn at reception, not a bowl, but a giant bucket. And I ate so much of it. I ate so much of it. And candy corn is the type of thing where I just eat it and eat it and then it turns on me. I'm like, stop. Am I remembering this right that BJ loved it too?
也不是真的。我是说，听起来确实很像连环杀手。听起来真的很像绞杀魔会说的话。确实如此。不能说。然后他又说“也不是真的”。还笑了一声。我只是说，这是在糖果袋里发现的。好吧，你的糖果袋很棒，我只在2分39秒时捕捉到了糖果的镜头，接待处放着一大桶糖果玉米，不是一碗，而是一个巨大的桶。我吃了好多那个。我吃了好多那个。糖果玉米这种东西就是，我一吃就停不下来，然后它就会开始让我难受。我在想，停下吧。我没记错吧，BJ也超爱这东西？
Yes. BJ loves all prop food. Even if he doesn't like that food in real life, if it's a prop, he likes it. That's Mindy too. Yep. I decided to do a deep dive on candy corn. What? And what I found might cause you to never eat it again. I doubt it.
对。BJ喜欢所有的道具食物。哪怕他在现实生活中并不喜欢那种食物，只要它是道具，他就喜欢。明迪也是这样。对。我决定对糖果玉米进行一次深度挖掘。什么？我发现的东西可能会让你再也不想吃它了。我才不信呢。
I love it. I can't resist it. Well, hear me out. You know, I love it, but I maybe learned too much. I've seen too much now. You know how that happens. The curtain was opened. Well, I watched that documentary. My octopus friend, I'll never eat octopus again, I'll say that. They're so smart. I know. So here we go, deep dive on candy corn. Here's what it's made up of.
我太爱它了。我根本抗拒不了。好吧，听我解释。你知道我爱吃，但我也许了解得太多了。我现在知道得太多了。你知道那种感觉。真相被揭开了。好吧，我看过那部纪录片《我的章鱼老师》，我发誓我再也不吃章鱼了。它们太聪明了。我懂。所以，我们开始吧，深入挖掘糖果玉米。以下是它的配方成分。
Corn syrup, confectioners glaze, salt, dextrose, gelatin, sesame oil, artificial flavor, honey, and three different food colorings. That all sounds fine, right? Nothing alarming. Now gelatin is derived from animal parts, is made up of like hide and bone, and so candy corn is not vegan. It's in everything. It's in everything. It's not vegan. If you're vegan, you have to really look for the gelatin. And you also probably have to take vitamins and stuff that are real chalky. Oh, because of the gelatin in a lot of I love it. That's where your brain went. You were like, I feel better people have to
玉米糖浆、糖果釉、盐、右旋糖、明胶、芝麻油、人工香料、蜂蜜，以及三种不同的食用色素。听起来都没什么问题吧？没有什么让人警惕的。现在，明胶是从动物身体部位提取的，基本上是由兽皮和骨头制成的，所以糖果玉米并不是纯素的。这东西无处不在。到处都有。它不是纯素的。如果你是纯素主义者，你真的得仔细检查有没有明胶。而且你大概还得吃各种粉笔末似的那种维生素。哦，因为很多东西里都有明胶我超爱。你的思路直接跳到那儿去了。你当时想，我觉得人们必须得
take the chalky vitamin, but I get it. Some vitamins are really big and the little, you know, slick gelatin coating makes the slide down. That's what she said. Okay. Well, speaking of a slick coding, Candy Corn has a slick coding. Love your it's true. Your way of finding transitions. I literally speaking of slick coding. Well, here's the thing, Angela, in my document, I actually wrote candy corn has a slick outer coating. I mean, it's right here.
吃那种粉笔末一样的维生素，但我懂。有些维生素真的很大，而那个小小的，你知道的，滑溜溜的明胶涂层能让它更容易吞下去。这就是她说的。好吧。说到滑溜溜的涂层，糖果玉米也有一层滑溜溜的涂层。我太喜欢你的了，确实如此。你找转折的切入点太绝了。我简直是“说到滑溜溜的涂层”。好吧，事情是这样的，安吉拉，在我的资料里，我其实写了“糖果玉米有一层滑溜溜的外涂层”。我是说，它就在这儿。
You played right into it. So the slick coating on candy corn is made from lac resin. Do you know what lac resin is? Is that like what you use on your violin? Like when you, yes, it is a secretion from tiny red insects called black bugs. And if you ever want to eat candy corn again, don't look up a picture of it. It looks like gelatinous poop on a stick. I've got a number of these bugs.
你完全掉进我设好的梗里了。所以，糖果玉米上的那层滑溜溜的涂层是用虫胶树脂制成的。你知道什么是虫胶树脂吗？是不是就像你在小提琴上用的那种？比如当你，是的，它是从一种叫紫胶虫的微小红色昆虫的分泌物。如果你还想再吃糖果玉米的话，千万不要去搜它的照片。它看起来就像是一根棍子上粘着一坨胶状便便。我有好多这种小虫子。
Like the blob. Have you ever seen the movie The Blob? As the blob goes up someone's hand and is like eating them. That's what it looks like. But this ingredient causes the candy corn to turn hard and that's why you can leave it in a bowl throughout Halloween season or a bucket and it doesn't, you know, go stale. The lack resin. I have no problem eating a bug. We probably all eat a bug every day, but it's like bug poop. Well, it's like a bug secretion.
就像《变形怪体》里的那个怪物。你看过电影《变形怪体》吗？当那个怪物爬上某人的手，像是在吃掉他们一样。看起来就是这样。但这个成分会让糖果玉米变硬，这就是为什么你可以把它放在万圣节季节的碗里或桶里一整季，而它却不会变质的原因。虫胶树脂。吃虫子对我来说没问题。我们大概每天都在吃虫子，但这感觉像虫子便便。好吧，这就像是虫子的分泌物。
If you eat a bug, eat all the bug. Okay, I'm just saying, isn't there like some like statistic out there that at least once a day we eat a bug, we don't even know it. Like in our sleep, like something crawls in our mouth or something, why would you say that? Why is that in my head now? That a bug's are falling in my mouth.
如果你要吃虫子，就把整只虫子都吃掉。好吧，我只是想说，难道没有什么统计数据说，我们每天至少有一次会吃到虫子，甚至自己都不知道吗？比如在睡梦中，有什么东西爬进我们嘴里之类的，你为什么要说这个？为什么这句话现在一直在我的脑子里挥之不去？虫子掉进我的嘴里。
You know what? I'm realizing I'm like horrifying. I feel like I just like I just pitched an idea to Gabe for his weird movies. Sure did. Well there you have it. Everything you wanted to know about Candy Corn. I'm still going to eat it. I'll eat that insect poop. Great. I probably will too. Moving on, Andy is not- No wait, I don't want to move on. I think my- I want to learn more about candy corn. Okay. What's Andy up to? Oh, he got a text. Robert California is coming. Now he's really scared. It scared the bleep out of him. Is there a lip flap? Please tell me. Oh wait, what is happening? Sam is sharing something. Oh God. Is there a museum where we can see bugs doing it's an urban legend, Angela?
你知道吗？我突然意识到我简直太可怕了。我觉得我刚才就像是在给盖比的诡异电影构思点子一样。确实是的。好吧，这就是全部了。关于糖果玉米，你想知道的一切都在这儿了。我还是要吃。我要吃那些昆虫便便。太棒了。我大概也会吃。接着说，安迪没有——等一下，我不想接着说。我觉得我的——我想了解更多关于糖果玉米的知识。好吧。安吉在忙什么？哦，他收到了一条短信。罗伯特·卡利福尼亚要来了。现在他真的吓坏了。这把他吓得魂飞魄散。有消音吗？快告诉我。哦等等，发生什么事了？萨姆在分享什么。天哪。有没有一个博物馆能让我们看到虫子在交配——那是个都市传说，安吉拉？
It's an urban legend that you swallow spiders in your sleep. Man, you unknowingly swallow an average of four live spiders in your sleep each year. This is a myth. Now look up how often in a day do we eat a bug like a nat or something? What is your mouth just open all the time? I mean what scenario are you just inhaling and digesting these bugs all day. Closure miles, bug don't find. Oh my gosh, that's making me laugh. Oh, here's from Sam already.
你在睡梦中会吞下蜘蛛是个都市传说。天哪，你在睡梦中不知不觉平均每年会吞下四只活蜘蛛。这是个谣言。现在去查查看，我们在一天里到底有多频繁会吃到像蚊虫这样的小虫子？难道你的嘴是一直大大张开的吗？我是说，到底是在什么场景下，你会整天都在吸入并消化这些虫子。闭上嘴巴，虫子就找不到了。哦天哪，这把我逗笑了。哦，萨姆已经发来资料了。
The average person unknowingly eats a surprisingly high number of bugs each year. Thank you. Thank you. The average person consumes up to one and a half pounds of insects annually through fruits and vegetables. That amounts to about 440 to 660 bugs in a year. Thank you. But not for just crawling in or flying into your mouth at random because they're on something that you're actively choosing to ingest. Whatever I said.
普通人每年都会不知不觉地吃掉数量惊人的虫子。谢谢你。谢谢你。普通人每年通过水果和蔬菜会摄入多达一磅半的昆虫。这相当于一年大约吃掉了440到660只虫子。谢谢。但它们不是随机爬进或飞进你嘴里的，因为它们就在你主动选择吃下去的食物上。不管我刚才说了什么。
Whatever I thought. Whatever I thought. My point stands. We all eat bugs. My point stands. Okay. We'll let it lie. We will.
不管我之前怎么想的。不管我怎么想的。我的观点依然成立。我们所有人都在吃虫子。我的观点成立。好吧。我们不纠结这个了。好吧。
We eat bugs. We eat bugs. But they don't just fly into our mouth. They just fly into our mouth. But they get in there. Yep. Mm-hmm. Apparently they do. They do. One and a half pounds of bugs a year. Yeah. Things you didn't know that you would learn today. Thank you. Welcome to Office
我们在吃虫子。我们在吃虫子。但它们可不是自己飞进我们嘴里的。它们确实就是飞进我们嘴里的。但它们就是进去了。没错。嗯哼。显然它们确实进去了。一年一磅半的虫子。对。今天你才知道的事情。谢谢。欢迎来到《办公室
Ladies. Andy is going to ask Kangaroo Pam to fact something for him and this makes Aaron very uneasy. Why did he ask Pam? Is Pam faxing things in a special way that she doesn't know about? I have something to point out in this scene. My makeup is really thick. Oh, it's really thick in this whole episode, and this is because it was hiding my melasma. I got the melasma on my face during pregnancy, and it never really went away. And I treated it with, oh my gosh. Creams, you had so many creams. Cream, special facials, laser
娇娃》。安吉拉要让袋鼠帕姆帮他传真点东西，这让艾琳感到非常不安。他为什么要找帕姆？难道帕姆传真文件有什么她不知道的特殊方式吗？在这场戏里我有一点必须指出。我的妆真的好厚。哦，整集里妆都超级厚，这是因为当时得遮盖我的黄褐我在怀孕期间脸上长了黄褐斑，而且一直没怎么消下去。我用过各种各样的方法治疗，天哪。各种面霜，你用过超多面霜。面霜、特效面部护理、激光
facials, yada, yada, yada, yada. Finally, I just gave up and I let it take over my face. And now, it just sort of spread so much that it even did self out. That's my great skin advice everyone. Just let it go. Just let it go. I thought you looked beautiful. Thank you. I did notice my makeup was very heavy and I was like, oh yeah, I remember that. That was the Malasma years. We're moving now into the kitchen. Everyone's kind of gathered around, having lunch.
面部护理，等等等等。最后我实在放弃了，任由它占领了我的脸。现在，它甚至扩散得太厉害，把我的肤色都给均匀覆盖了。这就是我给所有人的绝佳皮肤护理建议。顺其自然吧。随它去吧。我觉得你看起来很美。谢谢。我确实注意到我的妆非常浓，当时我就想，哦对，我记起来了。那正是黄褐斑的岁月。我们现在转到厨房。大家都聚在一起吃午饭。
And Phyllis says that she and Bob are doing a Scranton haunted walking tour. Well, this got me curious. Is there such thing as a Scranton haunted walking tour? And guess what I found? What? There is! It is called Scranton After Dark. I really want to do this, Janet. Listen to it. Come celebrate Halloween and Scranton with a bit of history with the Lackawanna Historical Societies. Scranton After Dark, haunted walking tours, you get a guided walking tour around downtown Scranton for tales of mayhem and mysterious happenings at some of your favorite places, the guides weave a candlelight path, imparting tales of tragic events, curious occurrences,
菲莉丝说她和鲍勃要参加一个斯克兰顿闹鬼步行游。这可把我勾起了好奇心。真的有什么斯克兰顿闹鬼步行游吗？你猜我发现了什么？什么？真有！它叫“夜幕降临斯克兰顿”。詹娜，我真的好想去参加这个。听听看。快来和拉克万纳历史学会一起，伴着一点历史来斯克兰顿庆祝万圣节吧。“夜幕降临斯克兰顿”，闹鬼步行游，你将获得由向导带领的斯克兰顿市中心步行游览，聆听在你的某些最爱地点发生的混乱故事和神秘事件，向导会举着烛光小径，讲述那些悲惨事件、离奇遭遇的传奇，
and ghostly apparitions that have become part of the city's lore. Participants are invited to attend a presentation by local paranormal investigators who reveal evidence collected at several reportedly active haunted locations within the city. Wow, $15 a person I want to go. I'll go. How fun would that be? We need to go to Scranton. We'll spend like a whole week there eating in all the places and seeing all the things. I know. Well, in this scene, Pam tells Phyllis that they have to go to the Banshee pub because Pam had a ghostly encounter there.
以及已经成为这座城市传说一部分的幽灵显现。参与者受邀参加由当地超自然现象调查员带来的演讲，他们会展示在市内几个据报道活跃着鬼魂的闹鬼地点收集到的证据。哇，一个人只要15美元，我想去。我也要去。那该有多好玩啊！我们得去一趟斯克兰顿。我们要在那儿呆整整一周，把所有地方的美食都吃遍，把所有的景致都看个够。我知道。好吧，在这个场景里，帕姆告诉菲莉丝她们必须去女妖酒吧，因为帕姆曾在那里遭遇过鬼魂。
With the man in black. Yes, she says when she was 22 years old, she worked at the pub and that she was looking up into the mirror and she saw a man standing behind her over her shoulder, the man in black. And then when she turned around, he wasn't there. And she told people about it and they were like, oh yes, this is the ghost. This is the man in black. Well, we got a fan mail, Flurry, Angela, because during the murder murder episode I talked about my real life encounter with the lavender lady when I worked at the murder mystery dinner theater place in st. Louis. And they wanted to know if by any chance the inspiration for pamps man and black story was based on my lavender lady story. And yes, it absolutely was the The writers used my Lavender Lady story. However, the Banshee Bar that Pam mentions is actually a haunted bar in Scranton. It's probably on the tour you were talking about.
那个黑衣男子。对，她说她22岁的时候在那家酒吧工作，有一次她抬头看着镜子，看到身后、肩膀上方站着一个男人，那个黑衣男人。然后当她转过身时，人却不在了。她把这事告诉了其他人，他们的反应是，哦对，这就是那个鬼魂。这就是那个黑衣男人。好吧，我们收到了一封粉丝邮件，安吉拉，因为在谋杀之谜那一集里，当我还在圣路易斯的谋杀之谜晚餐剧场工作时，我谈到了我现实中遭遇薰衣草女士的经历。他们想知道，帕姆的黑衣男子故事的灵感会不会碰巧是以我的薰衣草女士故事为基础的。答案是肯定的，完全就是。编剧们用了我的薰衣草女士的故事。不过，帕姆提到的女妖酒吧实际上是斯克兰顿的一家闹鬼酒吧。它可能就在你刚才提到的那个旅游路线里。
I was going to say I bet it's on the tour. However, in 2017 it changed ownership. It's now called AV restaurant and lounge and it was recently named the most haunted restaurant in Pennsylvania By the food network put it on our list. We're going however the man in black was a fictional story that we made up at The actual AV restaurant and lounge staff have felt hands on their shoulders Even though no one is there, they've seen glasses randomly break. And they've heard tables moving on the second floor, even though no one's up there. I'm not going to the second floor. Really? Okay, if you go with me.
我刚想说我敢打赌它就在那个路线里。不过，它在2017年易主了。现在叫AV餐厅兼酒廊，最近还被美食频道评为宾夕法尼亚州闹鬼最严重的餐厅。把它加入我们的清单。我们去定了。不过那个黑衣男人是我们编造的虚构故事。真实的AV餐厅兼酒廊的工作人员确实曾感觉到肩膀上有手在碰他们，尽管周围根本没有人，他们还看到玻璃无缘无故地碎掉。而且他们还听到二楼有桌子在移动的声音，尽管二楼根本没人。我可不去二楼。真的吗？好吧，如果你跟我一起去的话。
So the cool thing was that the Food Network did an article where they listed the most haunted restaurant in every single state in the United States. So this was the most haunted in Pennsylvania. And the one that I worked for was named the most haunted restaurant in Missouri. Oh, no way. Yes. I looked through some of the other states and there's just one more that I want to highlight. Okay, it's the cruise room in Colorado.
最酷的是，美食频道曾做过一篇文章，列出了美国每一个州闹鬼最严重的餐厅。所以这是宾夕法尼亚州闹鬼最严重的。而我以前工作的那家则被评为密苏里州闹鬼最严重的餐厅。哦，不会吧。对的。我浏览了其他一些州，还有一个州是我特别想拿出来讲讲的。好吧，就是科罗拉多州的克鲁斯酒吧。
It's inside the Oxford Hotel. And I guess this hotel is famous because it has a ghost, a man who comes in wearing a post office uniform. Stop it. He orders a beer and then he mutters, the children, I have to get the gifts to the children. And then he drinks his beer and he leaves. But when the bartender goes to take the beer away, it's still full. The legend is that back in the 1930s, there was a postal worker on his way to
它在牛津酒店内部。我猜这家酒店很有名是因为它有一个鬼魂，一个穿着邮政制服进来的男人。别开玩笑了。他点了一杯啤酒，然后嘟囔着，孩子们，我必须把礼物送到孩子们手里。接着他喝了啤酒就离开了。但当酒保去把啤酒收走时，那杯酒竟然还是满的。传说在20世纪30年代，曾有一个邮政工人在去
deliver children's Christmas presents in central city, but the gifts were never delivered. He went missing, and later that spring his body was found with all of the Christmas gifts still with him. Found where? Didn't say. Like, did he freeze to death or something? Don't know. Was he on horseback? No idea. Okay. But he can sometimes be seen going to the cruise room in Colorado and having a beer He's still worried about the Christmas presents. He wasn't so worried. He had a beer This is his spirit is having a beer I know but I'm just saying
中部城市派送儿童圣诞礼物的路上，结果礼物再也没有送达。他失踪了，后来到了那个春天，人们找到了他的尸体，而所有的圣诞礼物都还在他身上。在哪被找到的？没说。比如，他是冻死在路上了吗？不知道。他是骑着马吗？完全不知道。好吧。但人们有时还是能看到他去科罗拉多州的克鲁斯酒吧喝杯啤酒。他还在担心圣诞礼物的事。他当时并没有那么担心。他还喝了杯啤酒。这就是他的鬼魂在喝啤酒。我知道，但我只是在想，
What would you have him do? deliver the presents You want to see him as a ghost going around to children's houses and showing up? I'd mind you to go to the bar. I don't want to judge him, but maybe if he hadn't stopped for a beer, they would have had their presents. His ghost stops for a beer and is upset about not delivering
你希望他怎么做？去派送礼物啊。你想看到他作为一个鬼魂四处去孩子们的家里现身吗？我介意他去酒吧。我可不想评判他，但也许如果他没有停下来喝杯啤酒，他们就能拿到礼物了。他的鬼魂停下来喝了杯啤酒，结果还在为没能送出礼物而难过。这是事后诸葛亮。没有任何证据表明他在失踪前、在现实生活中停下来喝过啤酒。
the presents. This is after the fact. There's no evidence that he stopped for a beer before, in real life, before he went missing. Well, I'm gonna let it go, but I kind of judging him. All right, Angela. All right, well, let's take a break because when we come back,
好吧，我不跟它较真了，但我其实有点在心里批判他。好吧，安吉拉。好吧，那我们休息一下吧，因为等我们回来，
Jim is gonna have a talking head where he just can't believe that his wife believes in ghosts. Yep, we've lots to say. I'm going to call this next scene. What the heck, Jim, in the break room? Okay, that's okay. What the heck? Break room scene, because Jim is gonna ask Pam,
吉姆会有一段单人访谈，在访谈里他简直不敢相信他的妻子竟然相信鬼神。没错，我们有太多话要说了。我把接下来的这个场景叫做：打破砂锅问到底，吉姆在休息室的戏？好吧，那就这样。休息室的场景，因为吉姆要问帕姆，
I mean, does she really believe in ghosts, you know? Yeah, like, what did she think it was? It was probably, just like, she missed saw something. And he's totally being that little pass of aggressive judgey, you know? And she's like, I told you this on our first date. And he's like, well, I had just told you a story about meeting the Blue Angels
我是说，她难道真的相信有鬼吗？你知道的。对，比如，她觉得那是什么？那可能只是，她看错了什么东西而已。而他完全表现得像那种有点被动攻击又爱评头论足的人，你知道吗？然后帕姆就说，我在我们第一次约会时就跟你说过这个了。而他则回答说，嗯，我当时刚跟你讲了一个关于偶遇“蓝天使”飞行表演队的故事，我还以为你只是在试图跟我攀比呢。对。
and I thought you were just trying to one up me. Yeah. He's so taken aback that she might believe in ghosts. Well, we got a fan question from Aiden W. in Portland, Oregon, who says, all right, I have to know everyone in the studio, Sam Cassie, Angela, Jenna, who believes in ghosts. Sam, go first. I definitely believe in ghosts. And I encountered one much like your story years ago
他简直对她居然会相信有鬼感到震惊极了。好吧，我们收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的Aiden W.的一个粉丝提问，他说，好吧，我必须知道工作室里的每一个人——萨姆、卡西、安吉拉、詹娜，到底谁相信有鬼。萨姆，你先来。我绝对相信有鬼。而且多年前我曾遭遇过一次，就跟你的故事很像，
was bartending at a place called Poor Vooo which is a French bar here in Los Angeles and just like your story looked up at a mirror and there was somebody behind me and when I turned around to them they were gone. I have a question why do so many ghosts go to bars? I don't know. They really love a bar. But there was all sorts of stuff. Glasses would come off the shelves, bottles would come off the shelves, all sorts of stuff like that. Wow.
当时我在一家叫“巫毒”的酒吧兼职，那是洛杉矶的一家法国酒吧，就像你的故事一样，抬头看镜子时，身后站着一个人，当我转身时，他们却不见了。我有个问题，为什么那么多鬼魂都喜欢去酒吧？我不知道。他们真的很爱酒吧。不过那里各种事情都有。杯子会从架子上掉下来，酒瓶也会从架子上掉下来，各种诸如此类的事情。哇。
Is that your only ghost encounter, your only personal one? Yeah, that's my only personal one, but I believe I'm a hard believer. Cassie, my answer is no. I knew that you would not believe. I knew that your logical brain would not go there. Yeah, but I do have a reoccurring experience. I can't. Like, I think there's a logical, psychological explanation to it. But every time a family member or friend passes, a smell I associate with them, I smell it when
那是你唯一一次闹鬼经历，你唯一一次个人经历吗？对，那是我唯一一次个人经历，但我深信不疑，我是一个坚定的唯心信徒。卡西，我的回答是不会。我就知道你不会相信。我知道你那逻辑严密的脑回路不会往那方面想。对，但我确实有一种反复出现的经历。我不能。比如，我觉得对此有一个合乎逻辑的、心理学上的解释。但每当有家庭成员或朋友去世时，那种我与他们联系在一起的气味，当我在那个月里开车时，我就会闻到。但每当有家庭成员或朋友去世时，那种我与他们关联的气味，当我在他们去世的那个月里开车时，我就会闻到。所以现在情况已经演变成，我基本上只会说：嗨，拜拜。但这种事总是在我身上发生，所以我也不知道这到底是怎么回事。这发生在你得知他们去世之前，还是在他们刚去世的那个月内？差不多是在他们刚去世的那个月内。在他们刚去世的那个月内。
I'm driving like within that month. But every time a family member or friend passes, a smell I associate with them, I smell it when I'm driving within that month that it happens. So it's gotten to the point now that I'll just be like, hello, goodbye, but that always happens to me, so I don't know what that's about. Does it happen before you know they've passed or within the month of their recent passing sort of the month of their recent passing. Within the month of their recent passing.
所以这可能算是一种心理触发机制，但第一次发生这事的时候，我的朋友正坐在我车里，她也闻到了。哦。不知道。挺有意思的。不过，没有，安吉拉——好吧，我是说，你知道的，我完全相信——你知道的——那里有灵魂，我完全相信。你知道的，我没有经历过那种遭遇。我没有那种故事，
So it could be like a psychological trigger, but I did have the first time it happened. My friend was in the car with me and she smelled it too. Oh. I don't know. Interesting. But no, Angela Yeah, I mean, you know, I totally believe that you know There's spirits I totally believe it. You know, I haven't had like an encounter. I don't have like a story
但我有时就是会有那种感觉。故事是没有，但我有时就是会有那种感觉。有一次我在网飞的节目《讨厌鬼滚开》里工作，我们在温哥华的一个非常非常古老的建筑里拍摄，那个建筑在40年代曾被用作精神病院。人们在那里做过额叶白质切除手术。当时的感觉就是，哇，而且它现在是个危楼。有一半都被木板封起来了。另一半则出租给电视台和电影剧组。我们在那里进行夜间拍摄。有一次有一层楼，我们当地的一些剧组人员就说，我们可不去那一层。我们绝对不去那一层。
But I've sometimes just had a feeling story, but I've sometimes just had a feeling. One time I was doing the the show Haters Back Off for Netflix and we were filming in Vancouver at a really, really old building that was used in like the 40s as an insane asylum. They gave people lobotomies there. It was like, wow, and it's condemned. Half of it is boarded up. And the other part of it, they rent out to TV and movies. And we were there in filming at night. And there was a floor that some of our local crew members were like, we don't go on that floor. We don't go on that floor.
而且那一层连灯都没有。天色渐渐暗了下来。我们不得不把我们所有的灯光都搬进去，你知道吗？所以我们当中的几个人就觉得，好吧，我们从后面的楼梯间上到那一层去吧。简直阴森透了。现在我也不知道我当时是不是脑补了那里可能发生过什么之类的事情，但我对那里的感觉真的是厌恶至极。
And there were no lights on that floor. It was getting dark. We had to bring in all of our own lights, you know? And so a few of us were like, okay, let's go up the back stairwell up to that floor. It was so creepy. And now I don't know if I just built out what might have happened there or things like that, but I did not like the feeling there at all.
我当时就想，不，我要走回去了。我要下去了。我要去搬灯光。外联制片在哪？我要离开这儿。我太不喜欢那地方了。哼。你呢，詹娜？
I was like, no, I'm gonna go back down. I'm going down. I'm gonna wear the lights. Where's cross services? I'm getting out of here. I didn going down. I'm gonna wear the lights. Where's Cross Services? I'm getting out of here. I didn't like it. Hmm. What about you, Jenna?
好吧，詹娜。我觉得我家里有鬼。哦，哇。这听起来像是一首乡村音乐的歌词。我只是个幽灵。我其实不太想谈论这个，因为你可不想让鬼知道。我现在正坐在鬼的衣帽间里。这个鬼就在我的播客衣帽间里。
All right, Jenna. I think I have a ghost in my house. Oh, wow. That's a country music song. I'm just a ghost. I don't like to talk about it because you don't want to let the ghost know. I am right now sitting in the closet of the ghost. The ghost is in my podcast closet.
好吧，珍娜。我觉得我家里有鬼。哦，哇。那是首乡村音乐的歌。我只是个鬼。我不喜欢谈论它，因为你不想让鬼知道。我现在正坐在鬼的衣柜里。那个鬼就在我的播客衣柜里。
Okay. Okay. So does it record? No, there's a window in my closet. So this closet, the house is almost 100 years old. It turns 100 years old next year. This room that is my office has an old-fashioned closet that has a built-in vanity with a mirror and two windows next to it and then a cedar closet. And this was the vanity of the woman who originally owned the house. And this was like her dressing room. One of the windows opens on its own all the time,
好吧。好吧。所以录上了吗？没有，我衣橱里有扇窗户。所以这个衣橱，这房子快有100年历史了。明年就100年了。我办公室这间屋子有一个老式的衣橱，里面有带镜子的内置梳妆台，旁边有两个窗户，还有一个雪松木衣橱。这是这栋房子原女主人用的梳妆台。这就像是她的更衣室。其中一个窗户总是自己打开，
all the time. I will shut it and I'll come back at another time and it's open. It just is that way. I have come to accept it. She seems friendly. I think she just wants some fresh air. I don't know. Lee is convinced that the latch on the window is just weak. Lee is here. I see.
总是这样。我把它关上，过一会儿回来它又开着。它就是这样。我已经接受了。她看起来挺友善的。我想她只是想要点新鲜空气。我不知道。李坚信窗户上的插销只是不牢固。李就在这。我懂。
Close it open. But I'm like, I don't know. I mean, I have now over that window, I have like a heavy thick sound blanket, because I podcast in here now. And even still the window opens from underneath the heavy sound blanket. So like, what?
开着关上。但我心想，我不知道。我是说，现在那个窗户上面，我挂了一条厚实的隔音毯，因为我现在在这里录播客。即便如此，窗户还是会从厚重的隔音毯下面打开。所以，什么情况？
Yeah. I just, um, I just try to, you know, I just try to respect her space. Um, but I am convinced that I don't know. Something's opening my window. All right. But we're existing together now. I believe it. Here's what I won't do. I will never ever go on like a ghost finder thing where they come in and say on my house or like look for the evidence. We're just going to keep it how it is, which is in a real gray area, where it might be the wind, it might be the lady. We closed the window when it's open and we just all live our lives. I don't want more information. You don't want to confirm that someone died there.
对。我只是，呃，我只是试着，你知道的，我只是试着尊重她的空间。呃，但我确信，我不知道。有什么东西在开我的窗户。好吧。不过我们现在和平共处了。我信了。有一件事我是绝对不会做的：我绝不会去搞什么寻鬼节目，让他们进来查我的房子或者寻找证据。我们就维持现状，处于一个真正的灰色地带，可能是风，也可能是那位女士。窗户开了我们就把它关上，然后大家各过各的日子。我不想知道更多细节。你不想去证实真的有人死在那里。
She did. She did, I think, die here, but I'm not 100% sure. Yeah. Yeah. They say if you're not in a new home, probably someone has died in your home. Yeah. Well, thank you everyone for sharing. I guess we are what? 75% for ghosts, 25% no ghosts. Mm-hmm. All right.
她确实。她确实，我想，死在这里，但我不是100%确定。对。对。他们说如果你住的不是新房子，大概有人在你的房子里死过。对。好吧，谢谢大家的分享。我想我们这是什么比例？75%相信有鬼，25%不相信。嗯哼。好吧。
Speaking of spooky, how's that transition? I liked it. Robert California is gonna arrive with his son who's in a very elaborate zombie costume. And we're going to find out that Robert has a son. His name is Bert. Robert's going to give some Robert sass. Did you note the Robert sass?
说到毛骨悚然，这个转场怎么样？我很喜欢。罗伯特·加利福尼亚将带着他的儿子到达，他儿子穿着一套非常精致的僵尸服装。然后我们会发现罗伯特有个儿子。他叫伯特。罗伯特会展现一些罗伯特的犀利言辞。你注意到罗伯特的犀利言辞了吗？
About the party? No, about Andy's costume. Oh, he does. He's like, on this day where you can be anything you want, you choose to be a laborer. Yes, I wrote it down because I loved the quote. Robert Sass, and on this day of fantasy, you are a laborer. Yes, I loved it.
关于派对的？不，是关于安迪服装的。哦，他说了。他说，在这个你可以成为任何你想成为的人的日子里，你却选择成为一个劳工。对，我把它记下来了，因为我太喜欢这句话了。罗伯特的犀利言辞，“在这个充满幻想的日子里，你却是个劳工。”是的，我太喜欢了。
Well, the other Robert Sass I was talking about is how he points out kind of like the kitty decorations that Aaron has put up. Yes. And Aaron is so mortified. She's like, oh my gosh. And Aaron is so, you know, mortified. She's like, oh my gosh. And Andy's like, well, we have a better party. That's going to, it's going to get spookier and blah, blah, blah.
好吧，我说的另一个罗伯特式的犀利言辞，是他指出埃琳挂的那些幼稚的装饰品。是的。而埃琳超级尴尬。她心想，哦天哪。而埃琳超级，你知道的，尴尬。她心想，哦天哪。安迪则说，嗯，我们会办个更好的派对。那会变得，会变得更诡异之类的。
And this makes Aaron spiral. Yes. Well, something that Robert does like are the skeleton costumes that Gabe and Kelly and Toby are wearing. Kelly and Toby planned it. Gabe just kind of took it upon himself to join in. They even have a song. and a dance. Yeah. After which Robert kind of very casually but pointedly digs into Kelly's greatest fear. I loved this Jenna because remember I forget what episode it was,
这让埃琳情绪失控了。对。好吧，罗伯特确实喜欢盖布、凯利和托比穿的骷髅服装。凯利和托比计划的。盖布只是自告奋勇加入进来的。他们甚至还有一首歌和一支舞。对。在那之后，罗伯特以一种非常随意但又一针见血的方式戳中了凯利最大的恐惧。我喜欢这个，珍娜，因为记得，我忘了是哪集了，
they said how Robert California will zero in on someone. Oh, and make a small talk, but that it's horrifying. Yes. Well, Kelly admits a small talk, but that it's horrifying. Yes. Well, Kelly admits that her greatest fear is never marrying and dying alone. Yeah. And Robert's like very interesting. Then he kind of turns to Toby.
他们说过罗伯特·加利福尼亚会如何锁定某个人。哦，然后进行闲聊，但这太可怕了。是的。好吧，凯利承认了进行闲聊，但这太可怕了。是的。好吧，凯利承认她最大的恐惧是永不结婚并孤独终老。对。罗伯特就说，非常有趣。然后他转向托比。
And Toby's like, what? I mean, he's like, I'm fine. Yeah, Robert, California might be King of the Mind Games. He's clearly having some fun here. And it's going to continue throughout the episode. He's going to keep messing with people. He seems fascinated by what everyone's fears are. Angela and Phyllis are now going to start taking down
托比就说，什么？我是说，他说，我挺好的。对，罗伯特·加利福尼亚可能是心理游戏之王。他在这里显然玩得很开心。而且这会在整集里持续下去。他会继续捉弄别人。他似乎对每个人的恐惧是什么很着迷。安吉拉和菲利斯现在开始取下
Aaron's decorations from the conference room. And there's some real Angela sass here. She's like, are we able to really talk? Are we still sparing feelings? Because I hate all of this. You know, we had a fan catch from Candace R in South Dakota, who said, I have an observation I've been holding on to for like two years, since I first noticed it.
埃琳挂在会议室里的装饰品。这里有一些真正的安吉拉式犀利言辞。她说，我们能开诚布公地谈谈吗？我们还要顾及别人的感受吗？因为我讨厌这一切。你知道，我们收到了南达科他州坎德斯·R的一条粉丝留言，她说，我有一个观察憋了大概两年了，自从我第一次注意到它。
Two years. At seven minutes and 55 seconds, Phyllis takes down the skeleton decoration that Aaron put up because it's just not, quote, Halloween-y enough. However, in the very first Halloween episode in season 2, at 7 minutes and 45 seconds, you can see that same skeleton on the wall behind Angela while she is decorating. So that means that Aaron must have found this decoration stored away and thought it would be a good choice because Angela would have approved of this decoration in the past. It really makes you even
两年。在7分55秒时，菲利斯取下了埃琳挂上去的骷髅装饰，因为这实在不够，引号“万圣节风”。然而，在第二季的第一个万圣节剧集中，在7分45秒时，你可以看到那个同样的骷髅挂在安吉拉身后的墙上，当时她正在进行装饰。所以这意味着埃琳一定是找到了这个被收起来的装饰，并认为这是一个好选择，因为安吉拉过去会赞同这个装饰。这真的让你甚至
Saturn for Aaron who was so eager to do a great job at her first party that she even borrowed ideas directly from Angela who just ripped them right off the wall. Well, Candice, well done. That is a great catch. It is a great catch, Candice, but Angela gave her box of Halloween decorations to Jim and Dwight. I don't know where Erin got these from, and she might not have known it was Angela's box. Still, it doesn't explain why suddenly a decoration that Angela enjoyed in the past, she now is ripping off the wall with Phyllis. Maybe she thinks it's, you know, no longer great. But no, I don't think she has any irrational thinking here. I think it's just like
为埃琳感到难过，她那么渴望在她的第一个派对上做得很好，以至于她甚至直接借用了安吉拉的想法，而安吉拉却刚把它们从墙上扯下来。好吧，坎德斯，干得漂亮。真是个不错的发现。这确实是个不错的发现，坎德斯，但安吉拉把她的万圣节装饰盒给了吉姆和德怀特。我不知道埃琳是从哪里弄来这些的，她可能不知道这是安吉拉的盒子。不过，这并不能解释为什么安吉拉过去喜欢的装饰，现在她突然要和菲利斯一起把它从墙上扯下来。也许她觉得它，你知道的，不再那么棒了。但，不，我不认为她在这里有什么不理性的想法。我觉得这就像是
I've been given permission to throw shade at Aaron and I'm going to take it. I just noticed how many pumpkins are used to decorate the office. Like Aaron went really pumpkin heavy. There are, I couldn't even count them all. I got up to 14 and I'm talking from when you walk in the front door and the conference room. So many pumpkins. A variety of pumpkins, but so many stick up pumpkins. This got me curious, according to an article on realhomes.com about the most popular Halloween decorations. The pumpkin is not the most popular. Lombardo Holmes looked at Google search data and found that skeletons were the most popular. I was going to say skeletons followed by pumpkins. On average, people spend $145 on Halloween decorations
我得到了公开吐槽埃琳的许可，而我打算抓住这个机会。我刚刚注意到办公室里用了多少南瓜来装饰。就像埃琳在南瓜上用得太重了。有好多，我甚至都数不过来。我数到了14个，而且我指的是从你走进正门到会议室。有这么多的南瓜。各种各样的南瓜，但有这么多的南瓜立柱。这让我很好奇，根据realhomes.com上关于最受欢迎的万圣节装饰的文章。南瓜并不是最受欢迎的。伦巴多家居公司查看了谷歌的搜索数据，发现骷髅才是最受欢迎的。我本来想说是骷髅，其次是南瓜。平均而言，人们在万圣节装饰上花费145美元，
and they spend 3.3 hours decorating their homes and 82% of people in America decorate for Halloween in some way. Yeah, I mean our kids love decorating. They love decorating for any holiday. Forget it. Like every holiday something's going up somewhere. Robert California's son Burke really doesn't care about all the Halloween stuff. He is on Jim's computer and he is tracking hurricanes. He starts heckling Dwight about his costume, which he then is able to correctly identify as being carigan from Starcraft. This is going to start a little thing now between these two. He sort of
他们花3.3小时装饰他们的家，82%的美国人在万圣节以某种方式进行装饰。是的，我是说我们的孩子喜欢装饰。他们喜欢为任何节日装饰。算了吧。就像每个节日都会在某处挂起一些东西。罗伯特·加利福尼亚的儿子伯特其实一点也不在乎所有这些万圣节的东西。他在吉姆的电脑上追踪飓风。他开始对德怀特的服装进行诘问，然后他认出那是《星际争霸》中的凯瑞根。这将在两人之间引发一段小插曲。他算是
earns Dwight's respect. They know a lot of similar subjects. They really do. I think that sort of shows you what a child Dwight is, very childlike, and his interests, and things. We got a really fun fan letter from Jackie M. and Denver, Colorado that I just loved. Jackie says this, I am so excited about this episode. I'm a huge office fan. I usually rewatch it at least once a year, but my partner Jason had never seen it at all And when we got to this episode, he lost it. He is a huge starcraft nerd Jackie said I had no idea it was real outside of the world of the office Same Jackie same same Jackie goes on to say I've since learned that Starcraft has a huge cult following, but it's mainly in Korea and overseas. Also, this episode was so impactful on our relationship, because when we got our puppy a few months ago, Jason wanted to give her the name Carrigan.
赢得了德怀特的尊重。他们知道很多相似的话题。确实如此。我觉得这某种程度上向你展示了德怀特是多么像个孩子，非常孩子气，以及他的兴趣和事物。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州丹佛市的杰姬·M发来的一封非常有趣的粉丝信，我非常喜欢。杰姬是这样说的，我太喜欢这一集了。我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我通常每年至少重看一次，但我的伴侣杰森以前从来没看过。当我们看到这一集时，他彻底疯狂了。他是个超级《星际争霸》书呆子。杰姬说，我不知道它在《办公室》的世界之外是真实存在的。我也是，杰姬，我也是。杰姬接着说，我后来了解到《星际争霸》有着庞大的狂热粉丝群，但主要在韩国和海外。另外，这一集对我们的关系影响深远，因为几个月前我们买小狗时，杰森想给它起名叫凯瑞根。
And his logic was, it comes from Starcraft, which I love, but it's also a reference to the office, which you love. So needless to say, our little girl is now named Carrigan, Cari for short, and shout out to my sister Katie who got me listening to the podcast. Ah, I love that story. Me too! Erin is now going to confront Andy. She wants to know why Angela and Phyllis are helping with the party, and this is when Andy says, you know what, I want to talk to you about things, but we need to talk later, get the end of the day. Yes. And then he fakes that he has a phone call and it's so faking and bad. And Aaron is just so in her head, she's worried, she clearly still has feelings for Andy and I really felt for her. Yeah, I did too. She is so in her head and so nervous
他的逻辑是，它来自我喜爱的《星际争霸》，但它也是对你喜爱的《办公室》的致敬。所以不用说，我们的小女孩现在叫凯瑞根，简称卡莉，向让我听播客的姐姐凯蒂致敬。啊，我喜欢这个故事。我也是！埃琳现在要去质问安迪。她想知道为什么安吉拉和菲利斯要帮忙筹备派对，就在这时安迪说，你知道吗，我想跟你谈谈事情，但我们需要晚点谈，在一天结束的时候。是的。然后他假装接了一个电话，假得不能再假了。而埃琳深陷在自己的思绪中，她很担心，她显然对安迪还有感觉，我真的很替她难过。是的，我也是。她深陷在自己的思绪中，极其紧张，
that she's actually going to go ask Gabe for help. I know. She wants to make the party a little more adult, a little more sexy, actually not sexy, just make it scary and Gabe is delighted. But like he does his creepy laugh, he's like, I'll be back. It's true. This next scene is gonna get us a note from standards and practices. The finger. Jim is over it and he's old desk and he calls Pam
以至于她竟然去找盖布寻求帮助。我知道。她想让派对更成熟一点，更性感一点，其实不是性感，就是让它变得恐怖，而盖布高兴坏了。但就像他发出那种令人毛骨悚然的笑声，他说，我会回来的。确实如此。接下来的这个场景将给我们带来一条来自标准与实践部门的便条。竖中指。吉姆受够了，他在旧办公桌旁打电话给帕姆，
and he's giving her grief about her belief in ghosts. He says, why don't you draw me the man in black that you saw? Yeah, draw me a picture of it. So, Pam's like, fine, I'll draw you a picture of it. She holds up a drawing and it's clearly a middle finger. I really enjoyed the note from standards and practices. It says this, please blur the middle finger. And in parentheses, says this, please blur the middle finger. And in parentheses, in quotes, it wrote the bird in Pam's drawing. In case you weren't sure which one the middle finger
他正在为她对鬼魂的信仰而责难她。他说，你为什么不把我看到的那个黑衣人画下来？对，给我画一张。所以，帕姆说，好吧，我给你画一张。她举起一幅画，那显然是一个中指。我很喜欢标准与实践部门的便条。上面是这样写的，请将中指打码。括号里写着，请将中指打码。括号里，用引号写着，帕姆画里的那只鸟。如果你不确定哪个是中指，
is the bird, you know, the bird. And so we did. And I did not draw that, by the way, that was pre-drawn. There is no way I could have drawn that so quickly. So that was fakey drawing. I wasn't really drawing the middle finger there. Robert California is now going to walk over to the accounting area where there's a conversation about ghosts happening and we're going to find out who in the office believes in ghosts and who doesn't. Meredith shares that she believes in them but you guys,
就是那只鸟，你知道的，那只鸟。于是我们就这么做了。顺便说一句，那不是我画的，那是预先画好的。我绝不可能画得这么快。所以那是假画。我当时并没有真地在那儿画中指。罗伯特·加利福尼亚现在要走到会计区，那里正在进行关于鬼魂的对话，我们会发现办公室里谁相信有鬼，谁不相信。梅雷迪思分享说她相信有鬼，但是伙计们，
this scene was a lot longer. Meredith is going to tell everyone about her encounter with a ghost, and I really thought you should hear it. Isn't it? We're talking about it. I was talking about my wife and how she believes in ghosts, and then we had a little debate, and then Meredith said that she believes them too. Have you seen a ghost? Seen and banged. Can I met him in a bar, right? There's something weird about him. He doesn't smell right.
这个场景要长得多。梅雷迪思要向大家讲述她与鬼魂的遭遇，我真的觉得你们应该听听。不是吗？我们在谈论这个。我当时在谈论我的妻子以及她如何相信鬼魂，然后我们进行了一小场辩论，接着梅雷迪思说她也相信鬼魂。你见过鬼吗？见过还上了。我在酒吧遇到他的，对吧？他身上有点不对劲。他闻起来不对劲。
The clothes are all tattered and dirty and from another age. Anyways, we had to back up my place and we'd go at it all night. Married a thorn. No, no, I'm very comfortable with all things sexual continue. I wake up the next morning.
衣服破破烂烂、脏兮兮的，而且是另一个时代的。不管怎样，我们得回我住的地方，然后我们一整晚都在搞。梅雷迪思，天哪。不，不，我对所有关于性的事情都很自在，继续。第二天早上醒来，
All my stuff's gone. Whole house turned over. No trace. You told me what happened. Have you considered the possibility that you slept with a drifter? He didn't smell like a drifter. Oh my goodness. This ghost is our ghost in bar theory. Yes. Oh, Meredith. Also during the scene, it's revealed that Kevin does not believe in ghosts. You know, he's only scared of real things like serial killers or kidnappers. He's not afraid of made up things like ghosts or mummies. And then Oscar says, no, Kevin mummies are real. And he's
我所有的东西都没了。整个家被翻了个底朝天。毫无踪迹。你跟我讲了发生的事。你有没有考虑过这样一种可能性：你跟一个流浪汉睡了？他闻起来不像流浪汉。哦天哪。这个鬼就是我们的“鬼魂酒吧”理论。哦，梅雷迪思。同样在这场戏中，凯文不相信鬼魂这一事实被揭露了。你知道的，他只害怕真实的东西，比如连环杀手或绑架犯。他不害怕虚构的东西，比如鬼魂或木乃伊。然后奥斯卡说，不，凯文，木乃伊是真实的。而他
like, yeah, you're, you know, pranking me. And Robert's like, no, it's true. There's thousands of them. They're, you know, in museums, they've been mummified. This is the first Kevin's sort of it. And he has an amazing talking head. It's amazing. We got a fan letter from Kellyanne M. in Woodbridge, Virginia, who says, this episode has my absolute favorite line in it at 12 minutes and 27 seconds, Kevin's talking head, where he says, why on earth would a museum put a mummy in it? His delivery of this line is gold. He is so shaken by this realization that museums would house real life mummies. He even has a little whimper at the end, which makes the entire quote even more hilarious.
就像是，对啊，你在，你知道的，捉弄我。而罗伯特则说，不，这是真的。有成千上万个。它们，你知道的，在博物馆里，它们被做成木乃伊了。这是凯文第一次听到这个。他有一段精彩的独白。太精彩了。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州伍德布里奇的凯利安·M发来的粉丝信，她说，这一集里有我绝对最喜欢的一句台词，在12分27秒，凯文的独白中，他说：“博物馆里怎么可能会放一具木乃伊呢？”他这句台词的语气简直绝了。他对博物馆里存放现实生活中的木乃伊这一事实感到如此震撼。他甚至在最后发出了一声小小的呜咽，这让整句话更加爆笑。
I could not agree with you more. I love it. I don't even know how Brian made that sound. He made like a quiver whimper. Oh, he is the king of like these one line talking heads that just absolutely kill. Totally. Finally, the party is gonna happen.
我不能更赞同你了。我太喜欢了。我甚至不知道布莱恩是怎么发出那种声音的。他发出了一种颤抖的呜咽。哦，他绝对是这种单句独白之王，一开口就能把人笑死。完全同意。终于，派对要开始了。
We're in the conference room. There is a fog machine. There's some more spooky decorations and Andy's like, Aaron, you nailed it. Way to go. You know, we had a very hard time getting that fog machine to work consistently. Do you remember, Ange?
我们在会议室里。有一台雾机。还有一些更诡异的装饰，安迪说，埃琳，你太棒了。干得好。你知道，我们费了好大劲才让那台雾机稳定工作。你还记得吗，安吉？
Not only do I remember, but I have a video that I want to post. We talked about it in our book, but I really want to post this video. The fog machine broke and while they were trying to fix it, I mean, Kate and Craig and Ellie and Ed, they improvised a whole song. They made up a whole song. It was about the broken fog machine. It was so fun, and I'm going to post it. And then you hear at the end of it. All right. Going back to one of the fog machine was fixed. Yeah. I
不仅我记得，我还有一个视频想发出来。我们在书中聊过，但我真的很想发这个视频。雾机坏了，在他们试图修理它的同时，我是说，凯特、克雷格、埃利和埃德，他们即兴创作了一整首歌。他们编了一整首歌。那是关于坏掉的雾机的。太有趣了，我要把它发出来。然后你在最后听到。好了。回到雾机修好的时候。对，我
totally remember that. It was one of those times where there's a hiccup on set that turns into a personal memory. I'll never forget. Well, guys, Aaron has decided that it's time for a spooky movie. Erin has decided that it's time for a spooky movie. Gabe made it. It is cinema of the unsettling, which I looked up, I looked up cinema of the unsettling. Is it real? It's not real. Although there are like weird kind of movies in this vein,
完全记得。那是片场出现小插曲，最终变成个人回忆的时刻之一。我永远不会忘记。好吧，伙计们，埃琳决定是时候看一部恐怖电影了。埃琳决定是时候看一部恐怖电影了。盖布制作的。这是“不安电影”，我查过，我查过“不安电影”。它是真的吗？它不是真的。尽管这种风格里有一些奇怪的电影，
the actual terminology of cinema of the unsettling we made up. Well, it's basically a series of weird shots. And we really watched this video during this conference room scene because we shot all of the material for Gabe's cinema of the unsettling video the Friday before this week. I got some tidbits from Steve Burgess about the making of the video. He said, you know the shot of the melting Barbie doll in the microwave? Yeah. Well, first of all, that was a note from the studio. We could not use a real Barbie doll because we didn't want Barbie to sue us. So we used kind of like a generic looking Barbie-esque doll, So we used kind of like a generic looking Barbie-esque doll, but he said, guess what? They don't melt.
但“不安电影”这个专业术语是我们自己捏造的。好吧，这基本上是一系列奇怪的镜头。我们在会议室这场戏中确实看了这个视频，因为我们在本周之前的周五把盖布的“不安电影”视频的所有素材都拍完了。我从史蒂夫·伯吉斯那里得到了一些关于制作该视频的幕后花絮。他说，你知道微波炉里融化芭比娃娃的那个镜头吗？对。嗯，首先，那是来自制片厂的便条。我们不能用真正的芭比娃娃，因为我们不想让芭比起诉我们。所以我们用了一种看起来很普通的芭比风格的娃娃，
I was going to ask. Yeah, it didn't matter what they did. Phil actually had to have a like wax figure made so that they could melt it in the microwave, but it still took forever for it to melt. Steeper just said it was like a ton of editing to make that little moment look good. What the heck are they making the fakie Barbie dolls out of? I don't know.
我要问的就是这个。对，不管他们做什么都没用。菲尔实际上不得不做一个蜡像，这样他们才能在微波炉里把它融化，但它融化还是要花很长时间。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，要让那个小小的镜头看起来不错，需要进行大量的剪辑。他们到底是用什么做假芭比娃娃的？我不知道。
Unmelting things. I bet those are in the landfill forever. Steeper just also said, you know, the shot of the cake where the goo comes out. He said that when they cut that cake, it poured out. It leaked everywhere and it took forever to clean up. It was like a massive cleanup that one little shot. But I did not get any details on what exactly was in that cake. It looks like that blood syrup. It looked gross. It looked gross. We had a fan catch
不会融化的东西。我打赌那些东西会永远留在垃圾填埋场里。史蒂夫·伯吉斯还说，你知道蛋糕流出黏液的那个镜头吗？他说当他们切开那个蛋糕时，黏液涌了出来。到处都是漏出来的，清理起来花了很长时间。就那一个小镜头，清理工作简直是个浩劫。但我没有得到关于那个蛋糕里到底有什么的任何细节。它看起来像那种血浆糖浆。看起来很恶心。看起来很恶心。我们收到了来自
from Anthony L. and Louisville Kentucky who said in Gabe's unsettling video, we see a lot of gross things including cockroaches, which Anthony found interesting because in the episode China, we learned that Gabe can't stand the thought of cockroaches. Remember when Dwight puts up the big sign over the office windows? Oh yeah, the big banner. Gabe was terrified. He had to run inside. Yes.
肯塔基州路易斯维尔的安东尼·L的粉丝留言，他说在盖布的不安视频中，我们看到了很多恶心的事情，包括蟑螂，安东尼觉得这很有趣，因为在《中国》那一集中，我们得知盖布一想到蟑螂就受不了。还记得德怀特在办公室窗户上挂大标语的时候吗？哦对，那个大横幅。盖布吓坏了。他不得不跑进去。是的。
And so he thought it was very interesting that Gabe still included the cockroach in his film. I'm thinking maybe the writers forgot about that scene in China. Anthony also wondered if the writers forgot about the scene. Anthony, I'm with you. No one is liking this movie. And he's like, turn it off. Aaron is so embarrassed. And she's like, I'm sorry.
所以他觉得很有趣的是，盖布居然还把蟑螂放进了他的电影里。我在想，也许编剧们忘记了《中国》里的那一幕。安东尼也想知道编剧们是否忘记了那一幕。安东尼，我和你同感。没人喜欢这部电影。他说，把它关掉。埃琳太尴尬了，她说，对不起。
Well, I was trying to make the party more adult. I also have this Pecker poker. It's the card game that gets you, huh? It's the game of cards that gets you hard. Huh. Yeah. I did not Google Pecker poker just so you know, because I didn't want to see where the internet took me on that.
嗯，我只是想让派对更成熟一点。我还有这个“鸡巴扑克”。这是一种能让你，哈，兴奋的纸牌游戏？这是让你硬起来的纸牌游戏。哈。对。我没有去谷歌搜索“鸡巴扑克”，你知道的，因为我不想看到互联网把我带到什么地方去。
I think it's good that you didn't look it up, Angela. I'm not really sure where that would lead you, but probably nothing you need. Mm-hmm. Nothing I need to see. I don't need to see what's out there when you Google Pecker poker. Well, standards and practices had some things they didn't want you to see either. They said, quote, please ensure that no images show through the pixelated Pecker poker cards. Thank you. Again, do you see how polite they are?
我觉得你没去查是对的，安吉拉。我不太确定那会把你带向何方，但可能没有什么你需要看的。嗯哼。没什么我需要看的。当你谷歌“鸡巴扑克”时，我不需要看到外面有什么。好吧，标准与实践部门也有一些他们不想让你看到的东西。他们说，引号，“请确保像素化的‘鸡巴扑克’纸牌没有透出任何图像。谢谢。”再说一次，你看他们多有礼貌。
There's a please and a thank you in there. They like Steve. They clearly do. People really liked our reaction to Pecker poker. Angela Steve Berges wrote that it made him laugh out loud when he saw our reaction. Many people wanted to know if we were genuinely surprised because our reaction looks so genuine. But I know. We knew it was coming. I don't know. We just gave a good reaction that day. We did. So guess what? There's no coming back once you introduce Pecker Poker at work. Immediately the next scene is Aaron in Andy's office with Robert California. And he's asking her, why didn't you just ask Andy
里面有请也有谢谢。他们喜欢史蒂夫。他们显然喜欢。大家真的很喜欢我们对“鸡巴扑克”的反应。安吉拉，史蒂夫·伯吉斯写道，他看到我们的反应时忍不住大笑。很多人想知道我们是否真的感到惊讶，因为我们的反应看起来太真实了。但我知道。我们知道它要来。我不知道。我们那天只是做出了很好的反应。确实如此。所以猜怎么着？一旦你在工作中引入“鸡巴扑克”，就再也回不了头了。紧接着的场景是埃琳在安迪的办公室里和罗伯特·加利福尼亚在一起。他在问她，你为什么不直接问安迪
for clarification about what adult Halloween party meant? I mean, you guys are clearly very close. Yeah. And then there's that awkward look between the two of them and Robert's like, oh, I see. Well, this is now none of my business. but I'm going to say he's going to stay and watch it all play out. This is when Andy tells Aaron that the thing he wanted to tell her is that he's
关于什么是成人万圣节派对来澄清一下？我的意思是，你们俩显然非常亲密。对。然后他们俩之间有了一个尴尬的眼神交流，罗伯特说，哦，我明白了。好吧，这现在不关我的事了，但我会说他会留下来看这一切如何收场。就在这时，安迪告诉埃琳，他想告诉她的事是他
dating someone. They've gone on 31 dates. And it's kind of weird because he hasn't left this woman called the office or come by the office to kind of spare Aaron's feelings, but now it's getting weird and So he needs to tell her I thought Aaron was gonna like just Slowly die inside. I can't believe she even made it out the door. Ellie Kimper crushed it. She crushed it I felt her heartache. I felt her awkwardness. I felt her embarrassment.
在约会。他们已经约会31次了。这有点奇怪，因为他还没有让这个女人离开办公室或来办公室，以免伤害埃琳的感情，但现在这变得很奇怪了，所以他需要告诉她。我以为埃琳会像那样，在内心慢慢死去。我真不敢相信她居然能走出那扇门。埃里·坎珀演得太棒了。她演得太棒了。我感受到了她的心碎。我感受到了她的尴尬。我感受到了她的窘迫。
I was like, oh poor Aaron. The next scene, Pam is being questioned about her ghost sighting again. I know. I love that she called Jim out and was like, hey, how is this any different from you being superstitious about your jersey, you know, and not washing it. Well, I want you guys to know the scene was longer and a few people take Pam's side. It was cut out, but I want you to hear it. Please. If ghosts are real, how come everyone knows what they look like? It's not like a bunch of people got together and agreed on a lie. Thank you.
我心想，哦，可怜的埃琳。下一个场景，帕姆关于她目击鬼魂的经历再次被盘问。我知道。我喜欢她回怼吉姆，说，嘿，这跟你对你的球衣迷信、你知道的、不洗它有什么区别？好吧，我想让你们知道，这个场景更长，而且有好几个人站在帕姆这边。它被剪掉了，但我想让你们听听。请。如果鬼魂是真的，为什么每个人都知道它们长什么样？这可不是一堆人聚在一起串通好了一个谎言。谢谢。
Interesting. Every culture has this trope. Clearly there's some sort of real phenomenon out there. How are you on that side? This isn't about sides. This is about me seeing a bluish gray old man in the mirror and then he vanished. Pam, this is important. Was he me? Am I he? No, great. But that would make more sense. A blueish grey old man. And then the lead is amazing. Tell me Pam, was that me? But we learned in this scene that Stanley and Oscar are on the same side as Pam, and we know that Meredith is, so there's more people in the office that believe in ghosts.
有趣。每种文化都有这种套路。显然外面某种程度上存在着真实的现象。你怎么会站在那一边？这不是站队的问题。这是关于我在镜子里看到一个蓝灰色的老头然后他消失了。帕姆，这很重要。他是指我吗？我是他吗？不，太好了。但那样会更合理。一个蓝灰色的老头。然后带头的人太棒了。告诉我，帕姆，那是我吗？但我们在这场戏中了解到，斯坦利和奥斯卡跟帕姆站在同一边，而且我们知道梅雷迪思也是，所以办公室里还有更多人相信有鬼。
During the scene at 17 minutes and four seconds, on the light fixture behind Jim, there is a fake black crow. It is a decoration, however, I will have you know that more than once, more than twice, I don't know why, I would just catch that crow in the corner of my eye and it would make me flinch. This decoration really got to be, we were shooting this and I was very distracted by it during the scene and when I saw it, it was one of those things where I was like, oh my god, it's a crow. The crow. I remember the crow. It was just like the height of it, the way it was positioned. I don't know. That was a personal memory that I've now shared with all of you. We got a fan question from Carolyn B. And Philadelphia who said, in the spirit of this episode, I have to ask, was there ever a paranormal experience on the set of the office? Well, Carolyn, I did not remember one.
在这场戏中，在17分4秒时，吉姆身后的灯具上有一只假的黑乌鸦。它是一个装饰品，不过，我得告诉你们，不止一次，不止两次，我不知道为什么，我总会在眼角余光中瞥见那只乌鸦，它会让我吓得退缩。这个装饰品真的让我，我们当时在拍摄，我在戏里被它严重分心了，当我看到它时，就是那种让我觉得，哦天哪，是一只乌鸦的时刻。那只乌鸦。我记得那只乌鸦。就它的高度，它的摆放位置。我不知道。那是现在我跟你们所有人都分享过的一个个人回忆。我们收到了来自费城的卡罗琳·B的粉丝提问，她说，秉承这一集的精神，我不得不问，在《办公室》的片场真的有过超自然经历吗？好吧，卡罗琳，我不记得有过。
Angela, I don't know about you. I threw it out to the office text thread. Yes, we have a text thread with the whole cast called the Office Peeps that we are actively on. It is the sweetest, most wonderful thing. I love it when we all pop up on it. And Jenna put it to the group.
安吉拉，我不知道你怎么样。我把它发到办公室的短信群聊里了。是的，我们有一个跟整个演员阵容的短信群聊，叫做“办公室伙伴们”，我们一直在上面活跃。这是最甜蜜、最棒的事情。我喜欢我们所有人都在上面冒泡的时候。然后珍娜把它发给了大家。
Do you guys remember if we ever had a ghost or paranormal event on the set and everyone has been responding the whole entire time? We have been recording this podcast. Our phones have been buzzing because everyone is responding and it's getting really silly. Everyone's like, no, but now people are just kind of making up things.
你们大家还记得我们在片场有没有遇到过鬼魂或超自然事件吗？然后大家一直在回复，就在整个过程中。在我们录制这个播客的时候。我们的手机一直在震动，因为大家都在回复，而且变得越来越滑稽。大家都说，没有，但现在大家只是在胡思编造。
Like Reyn said, no, but it's currently haunted by the ghosts of our show. And Kate Flannery said, Reyn's right, the office will never die. Oscar wants to know if anyone's gonna organize an office sleepover at the studio. Yes. We could spend all night and get to the bottom of this.
比如雷恩说，没有，但它现在被我们节目的鬼魂缠身了。凯特·弗兰纳里说，雷恩是对的，办公室永远不会死。奥斯卡想知道是否有人要在工作室组织一次办公室留宿。是的。我们可以花上一整夜把这件事查个水落石出。
Then he says, unfortunately, I'm busy on that date. Date that hasn't been set. Well, I guess the answer is no. None of us remember or experienced a paranormal experience on the set of the office. But I thank you for your question because it has created a very entertaining text thread response. I have my favorite line of this episode. What is it?
然后他说，不幸的是，那天我没空。还没定日期的日期。好吧，我想答案是没有。我们谁也不记得或经历过《办公室》片场的超自然经历。但我谢谢你的提问，因为它引发了一个非常搞笑的短信群聊回复。我有我这一集最喜欢的台词。是什么？
It's when Robert California notices that creed is a little nervous around the fake snake. Okay. And Robert says, are you scared of snakes? And Creed says, you don't live as long as I have without a healthy fear of snakes, Bobby. I just love that Creed called him Bobby. No one else calls him Bobby. Well, this begins a series of little scenes where whoever Robert is talking to he's getting them to tell him about his fear and Darrell is afraid of being buried alive and Meredith
就是罗伯特·加利福尼亚注意到奎因对假蛇有点紧张的时候。好吧。罗伯特说，你害怕蛇吗？奎因说，鲍比，你活不到我这个岁数，对蛇没有健康的恐惧是不行的。我太喜欢奎因叫他鲍比了。没有其他人叫他鲍比。好吧，这就开启了一系列小插曲，无论罗伯特在跟谁说话，他都要让他们告诉他他们的恐惧，达瑞尔害怕被活埋，梅雷迪思
tells Robert the gym gives her the creeps Mm-hmm. And then this cuts to a Robert California talking head where he just says what am I up to? Bum bum bum bum. He then launches into a huge long story, mm-hmm, a creepy scary story where he singles out every person practically in the bullpen in plays on their fear in his story. Yes, the story has a snake.
告诉罗伯特，吉姆让她感到毛骨悚然。嗯哼。然后镜头切到罗伯特·加利福尼亚的独白，他直接说，我最近在忙什么？咚咚咚咚。然后他开始讲一个非常长，嗯哼，一个令人毛骨悚然的恐怖故事，他在故事中几乎把办公区里的每个人都单独拎出来，并利用他们的恐惧。是的，故事里有一条蛇。
It has someone being buried alive. It has mummies. It has someone dying alone. It has a tall slim man. Jim. Yeah. And it ends so oddly. Yes. And on that fevered night, she rushed to the nursery through open the door. Baby, are you okay? Baby said up slowly, turned to mother and said, I'm fine, bitch. He like lowered his voice. I was like, what is happening? To which his son laughs hysterically.
有人被活埋了。有木乃伊。有人孤独终老。有一个高瘦的男人。吉姆。对。而且结局如此离奇。是的。在那个狂热的夜晚，她冲进婴儿室，打开门。宝贝，你还好吗？宝贝慢慢坐起来，转向母亲说：“我很好，贱人。”他把声音压低了。我心想，发生什么事了？对此，他儿子笑得前仰后合。
Yes, everyone is just speechless. Yeah. And Roberts can explain what it was all about in his final talking head. He says, fear plays an interesting role in our lives. How dare we let it motivate us? How dare we let it into our decision making, into our livelihoods, into our relationships? It's funny, isn't it? We take a day, a year to dress up in costume and celebrate fear. There you have it. But this episode is gonna end with Bert going over to Toby's desk and firing him.
是的，大家都无语了。对。罗伯特在最后的独白中解释了这一切的意义。他说，恐惧在我们的生活中扮演着有趣的角色。我们怎么敢让它激励我们？我们怎么敢让它介入我们的决策，介入我们的生计，介入我们的关系？这很有趣，不是吗？我们一年花一天时间盛装打扮来庆祝恐惧。就是这样。但这一集将以伯特走到托比的办公桌前解雇他而告终。
He says, I'm the CEO's son and you're fired. So mean. I know. Dwight is pranking Toby. He's like laughing silently over the partition. So mean. At 21 minutes and four seconds, I noticed two things in Toby's nook.
他说，我是CEO的儿子，你被解雇了。太刻薄了。我知道。德怀特在捉弄托比。他在隔板后面无声地笑着。太刻薄了。在21分4秒时，我注意到托比的小角落里有两件事，
One good and one, huh? The good one is that there are a bunch of new photos of Toby's daughter on the wall. I love this detail. I love how our desks changed with us and with the passage of time. He still has his little puppy dog thing. He has a lot of things better than the same, but all the pictures on the wall, his daughter's older. He has a lot of things better than the same, but all the pictures on the wall, his daughter's older, Toby's daughter was played by one of our crew members'
一件是好事，另一件是，哈？好事是墙上多了一堆托比女儿的新照片。我喜欢这个细节。我喜欢我们的办公桌如何随我们和时间的推移而改变。他依然有他那只小狗玩具。他有很多东西和以前一样，但墙上的所有照片，他的女儿更大了。他有很多东西和以前一样，但墙上的所有照片，他的女儿更大了，托比的女儿是由我们剧组的一个成员的
daughters, and that crew member would bring an updated photos for Toby's nook. So new pictures, but also, that brings me to, huh? Which is on his desk, he has a mug with all of his pens and pencils in it, but it's a yellow NBC peacock mug. Whoopsies. Huh?
女儿扮演的，那个剧组成员会为托比的小角落带来更新的照片。所以是新照片，但这也让我想到了，哈？就是他的桌子上，有一个装满了他钢笔和铅笔的马克杯，但那是一个黄色的NBC孔雀马克杯。哎呀。哈？
What's that about? Long, long, long, long, long. Well, that was spooked, lady. Yeah. I think what I learned is there's nothing scarier than Robert California's zeroing in on you. I think you're right. I think you're right. I think you're right.
那是怎么回事？长，长，长，长，长。好吧，那就是惊悚女郎。嗯哼。我想我学到的是，没有什么比罗伯特·加利福尼亚锁定你更可怕的了。我想你是对的。我想你是对的。我想你是对的。
Well, thank you everyone for listening. Thank you to Steve Burgess and the office peeps text thread for getting back to us. And thanks to you guys for sending in your questions and comments. We just love them so much. And happy summer, everybody. We're going to take two weeks off. My birthday's coming up. Angela, once once again we will not be working on I know we won't be working on my
好吧，谢谢大家的收听。感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯和“办公室伙伴们”短信群聊给我们的回复。也感谢你们发来问题和评论。我们太喜欢它们了。大家夏天快乐，所有人。我们要休息两周。我的生日快到了。安吉拉，又一次，我们不会在，我知道我们不会在我的
birthday. Oh no. That's okay I'll eat cake for everybody. Well we'll see you in two weeks everyone love ya bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Keeper and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton.
生日那天工作。哦，没关系，我会替大家吃蛋糕的。好吧，两周后见，伙计们，爱你们，拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女孩”。“办公室女孩”由Earwolf、珍妮弗··费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基珀，助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
For add free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium.com For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, Use Code Office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需收听无广告版本的“办公室女孩”，请访问Stitcher Premium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。你还没有为这一集发表评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。